I'll go back to Jonah Hall Jonah is at
that ceremony in Oslo so Jonah there we
have it one individual and two
organizations awarded the Nobel Peace
Prize
yes Barrett rice Anderson the
chairperson of the five-person committee
appointed by the Norwegian Parliament
that makes this decision stopped
speaking a short while ago after taking
some questions from the media gathered
here as you say one individual and two
organizations named as the Nobel Peace
laureates for 2022 Mrs Rice Anderson
saying that in challenging times it was
felt appropriate to address the fact
that we are in the midst of a war not
just a war with huge ramifications for
all the people of Europe but also with
global a global context in terms of
nuclear threats and food shortages she
called it a bleak backdrop indeed they
had of course been suggestions ahead of
this that Vladimir zielinski the
Ukrainian president might have been in
the frame or indeed the Ukrainian people
the committee instead has gone for these
three individuals that Mrs Rice Anderson
said were chosen these one individual
and two groups for the work of all the
men and women in involved in them in
three neighboring countries involved in
this conflict to try and further the
aims of Human Rights and of peace and to
perhaps quickly run through again as a
reminder to our viewers who the
recipients of the 2022 piece uh award
Nobel Peace award have been Alice
bialytsky uh he a human rights
campaigner in Belarus one of the
initiators of the Democracy movement in
that country in the mid-1980s he founded
a group called viasna or spring in 1996
documenting human rights abuses he is
currently in prison in Belarus this is
rice Anderson called on the government
in Belarus to allow him to be released
to come here in December to receive his
award and as well as him the Russian
human rights organization Memorial
founded in Soviet times to document
abuses of people under the Communist
Regime it has gone on to document abuses
in Russia modern day Russia through the
Chechen Wars and of course more recently
prisoners of conscience and political
prisoners in jail in Russia they've been
shut down by Vladimir Putin their
activists refusing to give up and
finally in Kiev in Ukraine the center
for civil civil liberties uh founded in
order to document war crimes and try to
work with International Partners to
deliver accountability the three in the
citation through their consistent
efforts in favor of humanist values
anti-militarism and the principles of
law this year's laureates have
revitalized and honored Alfred nobel's
vision of peace and fraternity between
nations thank you so much Jonah Hall
reporting from Oslo
yeah
meanwhile authorities in Ukraine are
saying that at least 11 people